all right and welcome to in the video I
just entered the tournament here on
chess cube via two-minute tournament and
Tom it's a lead join I'm and I'm like
four minutes him was a bit bit late
alright so here we go first game in case
he really decides to play a move oh come
on yeah so I'm four minutes late it's a
bit bit of um catch-up game now with
four minutes is not too terrible trying
to win quickly here threaten a quick
made maybe Nyjah form
what is he doing now H to check mail
okay it's like to get it with the night
now with the bishop this ship is not bad
winter night is also not bad guess I'm
queen of three maybe ok or PM ok so what
should I do now I can also play move
like age 5 p.m. he takes age takes it's
just checkmate checkmate on foot with
the rook here k tries to protect it
right III though let's keep it simple
here ok this is this most to the
simplest of all I needed to go out
quincy one so i'm trying to play quickly
here
ya know if we can just pawn structure on
the Kings side a bit maybe I can play h5
at some point okay let's get rid of the
night jam I'm trying for a five if five
then you needs to go to a seven and now
my dears Queen to a 4 90 x e6 ok I still
have a very strong night only five don't
really mind this you know very very nice
position ok but how do I make progress
f4 might be an idea for black I mean
Rock to be three to be six would be nice
but this F for movie sound really really
a bit bit off-putting here okay yeah
this does either win sighs just complete
nonsense rook to be six okay buddy
cannot you cannot play c5 here can't
believe that so this is very close to
mate night twin 26 yeah 26 miss carner
move add this one and this I made some
home of course I could just take stupid
yeah checkmate oh sorry some the trading
here four minutes short
ok yeah the london system not too great
news for black if you want to win a game
quickly it's not particularly dangerous
but know that as yeah i should have paid
more attention here this was was bad
yeah I'm porn down maybe i can i can get
it back but some not very nice
now came the Sun these are two pawns but
it doesn't look so so bad I mean the two
pawns are not doing so much at the
moment it's of course better for wider
than everything and maybe winning but
it's not entirely clear okay now I get
one point back end I think I should take
it takes a clear okay five and a half to
two bishops against two nights this
might even be close to some compensation
yeah yeah he read he is no one point up
yeah difficult to play here
a year now is taking d5
only hope is so som some activity here
and it's not so well coordinated with
his pieces so it's not not really bad
but a bit a bit bit of something to play
for
it's got some weaknesses they cannot
move there the people at the moment a
force hanging for instance not sure ok
this one no b2 is so hard to defend now
bill on time here and now in the on
position yeah this lousy this game I
played the opening a bit too superficial
and got into trouble ok I've got the
hoops I've got a better off the end its
blundering a piece and somebody mmm can
I second age seven now maybe this is
good for four very quick win didn't
really calculate here yeah this should
be ok yeah it was otherwise were made on
winning winning the house
I was exceptionally quick but a queen s
are quite nice to have the extra yeah
Queen jisub checkmate okay in the hunt
shared second place immediately
disconnected once this I hope I get the
point after 15 seconds now this thing if
people don't respond to the doubling
cube otherwise it would be really unfair
to wait two minutes let's hope they give
me the point
come on really I need to wait 1 1 minute
20 for this yeah well okay yeah there
they actually had this some new thing
that you would get the point after 15
seconds of people don't respond after 15
seconds to the doubling cube that you
get the point which is a very good rule
of course and somehow this didn't work
out the end this guy here just lets me
wait two minutes and sports my
tournament yeah let's hope I get the
point at least sometimes it happened to
me that I waited all this time and then
they came some very weird error message
and basically told ya we got some
technical problems here and the game was
terminated and I didn't even get the
point and this is of course completely
nonsense so yeah 20 seconds you know
super super to watch on video the clock
ticking down tick-tock tick-tock ten
seconds I really don't understand people
don't want to play they can hit pause or
exit the tournament it's no big deal
yeah and only five points for this all
right oops no I don't want to resign no
miss click here
yeah it won't fall just so very uncommon
move either with black plate here gives
white quantum play in the center White
has play in the center anyway in the
green phone but this is a bit much
you know how to believe that this should
be should be playable maybe even this
not sure and now this was most badly
timed I overlooked the check here this
is a bit bit bit inconvenient now yeah
this is so yeah this was bad I mean this
was completely unplayable what he did
there giving me this youth center at
least I'm threatening a discover check
now not sure now we cannot prevent it
window bishop
now these pawns on the queenside a bit
of a nuisance
yeah I'm not too badly coordinated
should be ok
hmm this wasn't so great
got them the wrong wrong colored corn
here yeah but it's still winning very
bad technical player me but it's it's
still enough yeah the cheap one of
course win CH kon wouldn't have won so
who place one actually so I'm Sicilian
yeah I don't know when theory here very
well so I'm trying to play some solid
position on set up here 95 if I want to
play maybe immediately him a nighttime
might take with the night then ok
yeah okay the time will be a problem is
playing on his moves instantly almost
and they're not bad really okay maybe
this is a suicidal would want to get
something going here
maybe you can take Bishop takes 24 here
hmm it would be very very bad for me I
think yeah not really a great game my
pod not sure what this move is doing but
don't have anything right
maybe I can irritate him with those
moves I have six now okay I'll take it
yeah might be in some awkward pin here
but f7 is also hanging so maybe I can
can play move like this here first and
then see how to continue yeah but I can
take here this was the idea what if i
take if i take does he have a check rook
takes d4 maybe yeah okay let's give a
check first grab some some of those
pawns fool this wasn't too convincing
okay so i may be the last game here
let's hope for ya is playing it's good
non mover would have been really
annoying
I think I need to need a win to clinch
the tournament here it's taking lots of
time
yeah this should be good for me really I
hope Queen d2 Bishop before c3 I can
take you know yeah you can play 97
letter sir this isn't so so problematic
Wow let's grab the cookie first c2 I can
always play later yeah one decide i'd
like to take as well I only hope that I
manage this time wise not quite sure
what to say what's the remaining time
and i take c 5 volts or would have would
have been quite good okay it takes the
others made right yeah Wow some guy won
two games in the meantime Ryan I'm up
let's do wow so this is cool so I need
one more win and heater who I didn't
meet I mean he cannot win I shouldn't
win ok let's try to win quickly here
no way this is some quite nice to say
the least
yeah pretty dangerous a tech here
yeah this was quick the other guy one
thing when it came as well so I need to
try to win one more even so this must be
ultra-quick like in like instantly I Chi
form come on Kim Jiwan
come on I need a maid here then made
somewhere no this made next move Bishop
g6 Russia six made aha this was close
yeah mid next move ah and this was a
place to with just one more move and I
would have won this if it all right okay
so I've some some fun games and hope you
enjoyed it okay thanks for watching